you know what people like Robin this
shocked me the Instagram followers game
one person requests that we play a
version of this game with the whack pack
all right let's let's play a little
Robin I'm gonna name a couple of um
whack Packers and you first tell me
which one of these people has the most
followers okay that's easy
Jeff the drunk Bobo High Pitch Eric
tan mom Beetlejuice until you said
Beetlejuice I pretty much had a pick
who'd you pick beside Beetlejuice hi
Pidge Eric
however
now that you've thrown Beetlejuice in
there
I'm gonna say
no it's Beetlejuice you see you've got
an uncanny ability to zero in on things
you have a high IQ I've always
maintained that I'd like to have you
test it because you are 100 right
have you ever been tested IQ wise
a hundred years ago I was probably five
I don't remember anything about it an IQ
of five is very low you had to get at
least no I was five years old I see I
see uh Robin you are 100 right
Beetlejuice believe it or not has
2.3
million followers on Instagram that is
impressive and High Pitch Eric
has 5 000 followers though there's a big
disparity
so you got it right so who do you think
has more followers
Marianne from Brooklyn a show favorite
or tan mom
ENT
unfortunately you're wrong
tan mom has 10 800 followers and
Marianne from Brooklyn has 45
705 wow and no publicity no publicity
except on this show that's right all
right I'll give you one last one I'll
give you one last one since this was a
requested bit Bobo and Jeff the drunk
who has more followers
let me hear you I'm just thinking well
who's disliked more
that's a good approach I was gonna say
you got to take into account too Jeff
the drunk has been thrown off and put on
Instagram I think a couple of times I
think I don't know so has Bobo though I
mean Patrol has not had a clear sailing
in the social media world all right I
was trying to uh I'm going with Jeff the
drunk see this is gonna shock you Bobo
has way more followers than Jeff the
drunk you're kidding oboe has
3615 Jeff the drunk only has 890
followers Jeff I just get kicked off
okay remember Bitcoin Bitcoin damn it oh
my God they took my account they won't
give it back do you hear what he's
saying Bitcoin stole
that's right Mr Bitcoin hacks me
I don't know a lot about the internet
and Bitcoin all that stuff but it seems
to me if Bitcoin was gonna hack somebody
you tagged somebody who had you know
something like money or something yeah
but I know
50 that much the next and they both stop
saying what Robin like you can't
understand what he's saying
you're making the guy feel bad really
you want me to try to explain this
Howard or you're happy with this I think
I'm happy with it yeah we should leave
it I I agree
oh I'm proud to be
good my name is captain on the hill then
but y'all we before but we had love
that's one thing that Dad made sure of
beautiful tribute Thanksgiving oh no
he's keeping going
at what point is he going to realize
I mean everybody's saying
[Music]